the path Eddie your character struck by
lightning on the show and what I didn't
know is that apparently the gun real
research into it leaves you with a scar
but apparently is really the scar that
people often get if they're struck by
lightning is that all the scars look
pretty pretty similar to one this is
your scar on the show that you get when
you are struck by lightning and that
apparently I had no idea that that looks
like that's what it looks like it's kind
of like you know a Harry Potter has the
whatever the lightning bolt yeah that is
really something that people get and
what's interesting is a lot of people
survive in real life apparently people
survived multiple lightning strikes like
if you get struck by lightning the odds
of you getting struck again are very
high why would that make any sense if
you think the Lightning is talking to
each other up in the cloud we got him
let's get him again but apparently it
completely changes your genetic genetic
genetic makeup and yeah look we have a
crew member on her show her uncle I
believe Uncle Rick got struck six times
what it's true story look it up was
struck six times does he wear like a
tinfoil hat I don't know what he's doing
he's doing something that's face look
into an indoor job yeah but you can look
online you can see people I mean it's
you know it claims to have been struck
three times Martha Stewart true story
Martha Stewart says she's been struck by
lightning three now that's just God did
say Martha Jill out
himself cannot stop me from making this
plus option that's a true story you must
put the ketchup in another bottle other
than the bottle you get at the store I
like how you're a lightning person just
goes like that sure you're like Rodney
Dangerfield
yeah that goes that's crazy so yeah it's
sane yeah I'm statistic yeah do you
think have you haven't been struck in
real life obviously no let's just say
has anyone been struck no no yeah has
anyone watched the chew
[Applause]
you have as much like wow I don't know
what's wrong with me ladies gentlemen
I've got in for the two tonight we'll
take a break much more with hair and
paws stick around
[Applause]
you